you bust your bunker Oh what you gonna
do right
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
Oh what you're really early that touch
my sign yeah movie party I just what
movie are we watching
no you're early
oh yeah I know you didn't mean to do
that yes I did the party's not ready yet
well what is there still to do well
there's lots of stuff left to do but
it's better if I just show you take
something from the fridge and put it in
the microwave no no no no no no get the
water bottle and put it in the microwave
[Music]
all that damage your about Lee no no no
it's a new microwave it's the only find
it does this it doesn't think
yeah have you tried anything this not
food
well I mean well stuff that's not really
supposed to go in like metal
well you don't put metal in the
microwave exactly black you twine it
this it seems like it won't work
I mean plastic was okay what okay that's
just give Matt and he can help us out
still holding a mule I can't let me see
you like this what yes this I can well I
think it'll be a lot worse if you wait
just like throw away mark no let's stop
[Music]
[Applause]
I almost choked to death will we